[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
politique à table sur LCP la seule
émission qui a dit alimentation
agriculture écologique et un peu
politique et cette semaine nous recevons
willishman c'est vous qui allez passer
sur le grill et avec moi pour présenter
cette émission Jean-Pierre Montanet
bonjour Jean-Pierre bonjour Willy
bonjour Jean-Pierre
vous êtes président de la Fédération
Nationale des Chasseurs depuis 2016 vous
serez d'ailleurs candidat à un nouveau
mandat dans quelques semaines vous
défendez cette activité contre tous ces
détracteurs même les pratiques les plus
controversées comme la chasse à la glue
finalement interdite sous le dernier
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron vous ne
lui en tenez pas rigueur car vous avez
officiellement annoncé voté pour lui à
la dernière présidentielle il faut dire
qu'il a baissé de moitié le prix du
permis de chasse ça vaut bien un rendu
d'ascenseur conseiller municipal vous
n'êtes pas toujours très politique quand
vous déclarez il y a un an d'avoir rien
à [__] de réguler la faune pendant la
chasse surnommée le Tru de la gâchette
vous affirmez aussi l’idée que les
chasseurs deviennent des policiers de
proximité pour lutter contre la
délinquance rurale on a peur de
comprendre ce que vous voulez dire à
moins que toutes ces déclarations ne
soient en fait un goût prononcé pour la
provocation comme lettre un peu votre
menu du jour n'est ce pas Jean-Pierre
oui voilà qu'un chasseur préfère la
dorade au chevreuils ça sera donc du
poisson avec une sauce vierge des
épinards des asperges et en dessert oups
un plateau de fromage dans le dessous
des plats focus sur l'agrainage une
pratique qui divise chasseur et
agriculteurs il s'agit de nourrir le
gibier pour qu'il ne s'attaque pas aux
cultures dans les pieds dentelles les
chasses privées contestés par les
promeneurs qui ne se sentent plus
vraiment en sécurité comment améliorer
leur cohabitation avec les chasseurs
nous tenterons d'y répondre dans cette
émission
allez on passe à table tout de suite
cuisine et confidence
alors je sais Willy on vous l'a sûrement
déjà fait 1000 fois cette plaisanterie à
l'école à l'armée au bistrot il faut
sauver Willy du nom du fameux cétacé et
bien moi je dirais même plus il faut
sauver le soldat enfin plus exactement
sauver le chasseur Chan c'est pas facile
à dire le chasseur schran trop c'est
trop voilà qu'on vous invite comme fin
gâchette à déjeuner on s'attendait avec
Brigitte à des relents d'odeurs de
poudre à une gypse qui déborde de
perdrix et de lièvre un festin comme
dans Astérix avec du sanglier à gogo et
à table un chasseur qui assume de
défourailler dans les forêts et à quoi
a-t-on droit ce matin enfin déjeuner un
chasseur qui a troqué son fusil contre
un filet de pêche et qui demande du
poisson on dirait du Chantal Goya avec
son lapin et oui quel art du contre-pied
qu'elle feinte où il sera donc faute de
grive voilà du Suprême de dorade pas
vraiment durable en plus vous tendez des
bâtons pour vous faire battre vous le
chasseur on va vous accuser aussi de
vider les mers alors qu'avec un civet de
sanglier on aurait crié au génie des
chasseurs qui débarrassent la nature de
la faune nuisible alors vous tenez
toujours à votre dorade où il sera plus
jamais alors pour deux raisons alors il
y a deux bâtons à ça le premier c'est
l'enfance je vous en dire quelques mots
après mais le premier c'est la
contrainte parce que il y a 6 mois j'ai
mis un anneau gastrique et je suis dans
une phase d'alimentation où je dois
m'adapter et la viande sauf si elle est
très fortement hachée vos pose problème
donc c'est un câble que j'ai franchi
après avoir lutté contre mon poids
pendant 30 ans comme le font des
millions de Français d'ailleurs je suis
très heureux d'avoir mis cette anneau
gastrique mais si j'aborde ce repas avec
une bonne daube de sanglier il faudrait
dans ce cas-là beaucoup de temps surtout
pas parler et me concentrer un maximum
ce qui n'était pas possible mais la
daurade c'est aussi un poisson qui a un
message pour moi très fort de mon
enfance j'ai beaucoup péché de vendre
Dunkerque avec mon frère quand on était
gamin on adorait la pêche en mer et le
summum du summum c'était attrapé une
dorade c'est très compliqué il y en a
peu
il y en a pas beaucoup emmerdes du Nord
la droite grise alors encore moins des
dorades royales et d'ailleurs c'est mon
frère qui a pris la première et je m'en
remettrai jamais
vous pourrez quand même remanger de la
viande après une jambe j'en mange
actuellement mais je vous dis il me faut
vraiment que je me concentre et il faut
une viande très très hachée donc c'est
c'est voilà le repas et pour l'instant
un moment de concentration extrême mais
je pense que la viande n'est pas très
loin dans votre tête parce que vous nous
avez demandé un suprême de dorade et
alors nous on a pensé à suprême de
volailles donc on a pensé à viande tout
de suite et en réalité on a un filet de
dorade mais d'ailleurs naturellement
j'adore le poisson en tant que la viande
je mange beaucoup de poissons
j'aurais trois petites choses à vous
dire Brigitte parce que c'est très
intéressant les dorades il y a plein de
choses à dire elle est belle cette
dorade elle est bien grillée
trois choses à savoir effectivement sur
la dorade Jean-Pierre alors d'abord
c'est un poisson de mer maigre il existe
trois espèces et c'est la couleur de
leur chair et les reflets de leurs
écailles qui différencient ces trois
espèces la plus prisée donc la plus rare
donc la plus chère et la dorade royale à
chair blanche et fine ensuite la dorade
rose et la dorade grise appelée aussi
Brême ou Sahar c'est la plus courante et
la plus petite est-ce que vous seriez
nous dire si c'est une dorade royale
rose ou droite grise c'est une ah vous
savez vous le voyez comme ça
alors joue à la couleur à la forme aussi
mais mais je sens que c'est une grande
crise je peux me tromper on a bien vu
qu'on avait affaire un expert alors bon
chasseur alors chez votre poissonnier
préférez la dorade de pêche car la
dorade d'élevage n'a pas la même finesse
sa chair peut mettre être un peu
farineuse ça je pense que vous allez
acquiescer les dorades sont vendus
entières ou en portion prévoir 300 g
pour une personne elles doivent être
bien brillantes et ce ce qu'on appelle
un suprême de volaille est en fait un
filet de volaille
le poisson je m'emmène les pinceaux ces
poissons exigent une préparation très
soigneuse en raison de leurs écailles
nombreuses et collantes vous pouvez
aussi bien les cuire en filet grillé
rôti au four braisé poché au
court-bouillon cuit à la vapeur mais la
dorade est tout terrain elle est aussi
fameuse crue en sashimi en tartare ou en
carpaccio vous aimez ça aussi
les deux mais j'adore effectivement les
sashimi le poisson cru c'est vraiment
quelque chose il faut que ça soit très
très fâche là ouais il faut que ce soit
très frais mais c'est très très bon moi
j'aime beaucoup de poissons que je mange
comme ça et vous savez la cuisiner vous
aimez la vous aimez cuisiner tout
simplement
j'ai une chance gérer une malchance
extraordinaire mon épouse cuisine
extrêmement bien et mieux que moi donc
c'est souvent elle qui s'en charge mais
évidemment quand on aime bien manger on
aime un peu cuisiner voilà alors
peut-être aussi un peu par manque de
temps aujourd'hui mais mais oui j'aime
bien faire la cuisine
cette recette
parce qu'elle est passionnée aussi de de
ça qu'elle fait très très bien à manger
et voilà donc après voilà il vaut mieux
quand même se confier effectivement son
assiette au maître qu'elle élève donc
des femmes qui cuisinent quand vous
chassez par exemple gibier alors par
contre elle ne touche pas le gibier
c'est à dire dans le sens où c'est moi
qui vais tout dépouiller moi-même vous
plumez moi-même je j'enlève la peau des
des des des petits animaux comme les
lièvres et les lapins tout ça je fais ça
moi-même j'enlève les entrailles et tout
ça je fais moi-même je découpe pour
faire ça parce qu'il faut que ça soit
non même pas campagne lièvre vous le
pendez dehors et vous et voilà j'ai mis
deux chiens de chaque côté qui regardent
ça avec une émotion intense et beaucoup
d'amour et voilà un bon vide de lièvre
on enlève la peau on coupe les boules
quand j'étais petit
la peau du lapin comme ça
il y a aucun problème fait votre femme
comme recette de cuisine à partir de ça
des civets
simple de terroirs des plats
traditionnels voilà il y a rien
d'extraordinaire mais voilà un lièvre en
civet
vous laissez moi la bière comme nous on
aime le faire j'aime pas trop que ce
soit mariné je préfère effectivement un
jeune lièvre en civet comme ça à la
bière aux échalotes
c'est très très bon aussi voilà une
daube de sanglier j'aime beaucoup
parce que ça modifie le goût ça parce
que c'est un goût assez fort et moi
j'aime le goût du gibier comme idée
voilà alors déjà le gibier c'est des
fois un petit peu fort si vous le
marinez vous donnez encore plus de
vacances à la viande et pour moi c'est
trop fort je trouve que le gibier sans
marinade est délicieux manger comme ça à
racontez-nous d'où vous vient cette
passion pour la chasse
elle me vient depuis tellement longtemps
je n'ai vécu que dans ça voilà Brigitte
je connais que ça et et
parents sont chasseurs mes
grands-parents son chasseurs des deux
côtés voilà toute la famille tous mes
cousins chassent mon frère enfin on a
baigné dedans
qu'on baigne dedans donc depuis qu'on
était depuis qu'on était petit voilà et
puis il me dites-vous bien une époque où
vous savez dans le village vous étiez un
garçon bon on était des gamins on jouait
des des notes plus de neige avec des
frondes et des arcs attraper des oiseaux
en tuer un avec un arc c'était voilà
c'est naturel c'était tellement naturel
et tellement normal de faire comme ça
donc on avait le choix entre le football
et la chasse et souvent vous avez les
deux d'ailleurs la plupart du temps
comme dans le sud il était plutôt la
chasse et le rugby nous on faisait la
chasse et le football dans dans le nord
de la France voilà mais c'était tout à
fait naturel et depuis que je suis tout
petit je suis toujours allé à la chasse
et j'ai une passion inodérée quand on
est dans un milieu comme ça on peut soit
épouser ce que vous avez fait cette
nation parce que c'est dans l'ADN
familial soit au contraire être en
retrait et puis au contraire être en
rébellion en se disant s'il distingue de
massacrer ces animaux etc non vous avez
vous êtes posé des questions quand même
sur l'utilité de la chasse sur cette
tradition sur est-ce qu'elle devait être
pérenne sur est-ce qu'il fallait pas la
contrarie ou pas du tout c'était pas du
tout une question qui était dans les
repas de famille ça jamais été une
question dans les repas de famille mais
ce que vous dites vous avez raison j'en
perd sur un point mon frère n'a pas
chassé tout de suite donc c'est le bon
exemple de ce que vous dites il était
même intéressé du tout peut-être par un
rejet je ne sais pas après tout vous
avez raison peut-être trop de chasse tu
la chasse on va dire comme ça et par
contre il a passé son fils a voulu
passer son permis ou mon filleul qui
était très passionné de chasse et un
matin il me dit voilà je me suis inscrit
au permis de chasser il y a quelques
années il avait un peu plus de 40 ans
donc jamais même pas accompagné ton
petit c'était très très peu c'était pas
son truc du tout et il me dit un truc
extraordinaire il me dit je me suis
inscrit au permis de chasser parce que
je sens que mon fils est passionné je
veux partager quelque chose avec mon
fils je trouvais ça premièrement
intelligent de sa part et je peux vous
dire aujourd'hui il est devenu
extrêmement passionné peut-être même
plus que son fils et il m'a dit un jour
je sais pas comment j'ai fait pour vivre
toutes ces années sans la chasse il a eu
des tas de passion il dormait des tas de
choses et il m'a dit j'ai enfin trouvé
un sens à ma passion voilà c'est vous
comment j'ai pu vivre
nationale sur le bien-être animal
comment vous réagissez face à ça à ceux
qui disent bah oui mais aujourd'hui
c'est pas compatible finalement je crois
alors c'est pas compatible serait
difficulté avec ça je vais vous dire je
comprends pas trop ce qu'on veut dire
avec ça qu'est-ce que c'est le bien-être
animal c'est un animal il peut se
reproduire il peut manger c'est tout je
veux dire on va limiter quand même les
choses quoi c'est quoi le bien-être
animal je pense qu'on devrait plutôt
parler de cruo qui peut avoir alors je
sais pas des sentiments mais les
réactions des émotions et donc je pense
que vous allez loin dans les émotions
c'est pas tout à fait comme ça Dieu sait
si on les connaît les animaux vous les
connaissez mieux dedans
voilà les animaux domestiques sûrement
un mimétisme des fois avec avec le
maître avec l'homme depuis toutes ces
années sages peu longtemps un animal
sauvage reste un animal sauvage voilà on
a des réflexes qu'il a des réflexes sont
un chevreuil ou un prédateur il se méfie
il a l'instant vous êtes sûr que c'est
carrément en face de vous qui vous dites
non mais je suis pas scientifique mais
vous me parlez d'émotion c'est pas
d'émotion bien sûr je j'essaie d'être
mis de l'empathie ni de vous apporter de
la contradiction j'essaie de trouver des
mots je comprends que mais au moins
quand même une peur une frousse une
tentative de s'échapper du prédateur
donc des réactions qui sont quand même
qu'on peut partager mais comme n'importe
quel n'importe quel prédateur avec avec
sa proie je veux dire quoi c'est juste
une chose qui est dans la nature poser
comme ça entre trois arbres on peut tuer
on pourrait jamais se tromper j'ai un
beaucoup de respect pour le vivant
l'acte de chasse est très important pour
moi vous le savez mais préserver
effectivement le vivant c'est quelque
chose qui est très important et pour
beaucoup de chasseurs quoi qu'on en dise
d'ailleurs il y a toujours cette
contradiction que nous opposants ne
comprennent pas on peut se battre toute
une année dans la nature à faire des
trucs extraordinaires pour le pour la
faune pour la faune chassa et toute la
faune en général on plante des on
s'occupe des tas de trucs on met des
fleurs on aménage beaucoup beaucoup
l'environnement mais quand il y en a
perdu la chasse il y a aucun problème
pour prendre le fusil de temps en temps
tu es un lièvre ou un sanglier ou un
chevreuil et ça il y a beaucoup de gens
qui n'arrivent pas à comprendre mais
comment vous pouvez nous raconter que
vous êtes au produisez 4 milliards
d'euros de
écosystémiques pour la nature en France
et c'est ce que nous faisons nous les
chasseurs chiffrés par l'État il y a
personne qui fait ça et comment vous
pouvez prendre un fusil et c'est toute
l'explication en fin de compte de la
chasse comment moi je peux passer du
temps à m'occuper de de je vais je vais
même plus parler de la chasse comment je
peux m'occuper de mes volailles je suis
passionné j'ai beaucoup d'animaux à la
maison j'ai des poules j'ai des canards
j'ai des tas de choses j'habite dans une
ferme enfin bref je l'ai Buchan je les
vois naître et de temps en temps j'en
prends un je le tue je le plume je le
vide en Manche
par exemple moi je pense alors la chose
c'est quelque chose de minoritaire donc
moi je suis quelqu'un de très ouvert
comme la plupart des chasseurs dans ce
qui notre problème a du mal et du fasses
défendre parce que nous ne sommes pas
nous ne sommes pas dans cette volonté de
changer les autres on est plutôt dans le
fait de subir donc voilà celui qui est
flexitarien celui qui est vegan celui
qui est végétarien ce qui est plus que
ce que j'ai connu dans ma jeunesse mais
ça m'aurait jamais venu à l'idée d'aller
essayer de lui faire la leçon de morale
pour changer ses pratiques si c'est son
choix on est quand même des gens
extrêmement cool
mais d'ailleurs c'est à l'image de notre
société que ça se passe se dire au
niveau de la chasse ou au niveau du
monde politique ou dans n'importe quel
autre domaine aujourd'hui on veut régler
les choses par la violence en disant moi
je ne suis pas chasseur je ne veux pas
que tu chasses je ne mange pas de viande
je ne veux pas que tu en mange je ne
vois pas radicalité je ne veux pas que
tu votes Macron et j'en passe et des
meilleurs on est dans une radicalité
très très violente à l'égard des autres
honnêtement ça peut arriver mais
vraiment ça n'est pas du tout la major
la majorité quand on voit les forums sur
les réseaux sociaux alors etc moi qui
disent moi j'ai vu un chasseur il
voulait mettre sa gâchette Jean-Pierre
un exemple concret pour terminer
là-dessus quand même des gens qui sont
armés dans la nature si on était aussi
violent vous le dites forcément il
arrive à des catastrophes on se fait
quand même insulter comme c'est pas
possible moi-même en tant que chasseur
mais avant cela on va voir si vous êtes
incollable c'est le quiz
comme vous êtes un expert en cuisine en
poissons viande vous avez tout trouvé
votre passion a donné son nom à une
sauce qui accompagne le gibier la sauce
vierge chasseur alors ce livre
aujourd'hui c'est bien mais là non mais
alors la sauce chasseur alors
sauriez-vous nous dire oui quel est
l'ingrédient parmi ceci qui ne figure
pas dans la composition de la sauce
chasseur le cerfeuil le cognac la
moutarde le champignon de Paris et vous
avez le droit on a un téléphone vous
avez le droit d'appeler votre femme
comme dans question
j'enlèverai le cognac et bien non c'est
la moutarde il n'y a pas de moutarde
dans la sauce chasseur très brune c'est
vrai mais bon il y a bien du cognac et
même je crois qu'il y a du vin blanc
mais la notion de Cognac doit être très
faible
des régionalismes sur la sauce chasseur
allez hop
fleuriste dites-nous quelle est parmi
ces fleurs parce qu'il faut dire que
vous aviez beaucoup de fleurs c'était
votre métier avant et vos parents
avaient c'est ça une exploitation des
pépiniéristes fabrique moi j'ai vendu
toute ma vie des fleurs coupées
principalement voilà c'est ça vous en
êtes séparés un de cette pépinière j'ai
vendu ma chaîne de magasins il y a
quelques années oui bon vous restez
quand même fleuriste alors dites-nous
quel est parmi ces fleurs celle qui
n'est pas comestible et qui ne peut donc
pas décorer les assiettes des grands
chefs pas évident à l'adoniste de
printemps B la bourrache c'est la
capucine
dès l'aspérule odorante j'enlèverai la
spirule d'Orante là il a déjà un doute
les BC
sur l'une des deux
allez la Denise de printemps
vous savez qu'en France le repas occupe
une large place et particulièrement en
politique mais pas seulement souvent il
y a aussi effectivement et c'est souvent
là que se trouve les meilleurs histoires
c'est la brève de comptoir
alors oui les schran on vous a demandé
de réfléchir à une anecdote autour d'un
repas est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
raconter une j'imagine que vous en avez
des tas j'en ai des tas mais il y en a
une deuxième constance dans ces périodes
un peu politique
j'étais jeune président élu du
Pas-de-Calais il y a quelques années
maintenant et je me retrouve dans un
dans un groupe de président avec notre
président national invité à déjeuner au
ministère de la transition écologique à
l'époque c'était Nathalie
Kosciusko-Morizet donc on arrive là
dedans alors c'est plutôt tous des beaux
bébés genre moi quoi oui mais un petit
peu voilà moi avant mon anneau et je
sens je sens que tu suscumorisé se
marrer tout de suite quand elle parle du
repas on s'assoit tout ça et vous savez
que c'est pas quelqu'un qui mange de la
viande donc elle nous a servi à sauter
de navet
on est sortis de là il y a un marchand
de hamburgers là qui a 100 m du du
ministère de la transition écologique
sur le boulevard Saint-Germain on est
allé on s'est enfilé deux trucs comme ça
on en pouvait plus ça reste une anecdote
assez particulière
voilà mais maintenant le saura voilà on
n'a jamais voilà Valérie thénave c'est
jamais passé mais vous aimez la provoc
donc vous avez dû apprécier ce petit
provoque
peut-être qu'un jour je pourrais lui
rendre la moyenne de sa pièce j'aimerais
que vous nous racontiez oui votre
dernière rencontre avec Nicolas Hulot
parce que je crois que Nicolas Hulot a
démissionné et que la veille vous étiez
avec lui et peut-être avec le président
de la République oui tout à fait c'est
ça je vais nous raconter brièvement mais
bon voilà ça fait couler beaucoup
beaucoup d'entrée de salive à l'époque
on avait une réunion que le Président de
la République et bien sûr le ministre de
la transition écologique qui était là et
quelques autres personnes du
gouvernement et le but était la
discussion d'ailleurs qui était
principalement axé sur les chasses
traditionnels et Nicolas Hulot voulait
voulait réduire à sa plus simple
expression ces fameux chasses
traditionnelles donc le président a
tranché on a discuté cette réforme de la
chasse donc permis à 200 euros vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure dans votre
chronique et il n'a jamais rien dit il a
juste dit à la fin mais qu'est-ce que
moi j'ai pour mes copains
la phrase j'ai juste dit au président de
la République c'est quand même curieux
qu'un ministre d'État demande ce qui va
ramener pour ses copains et avant tout
le monde se regardait et le chef des
états n'était pas très content
tout le monde s'est levé tout le monde
est parti et là il est rentré dans une
colère terrible il y avait Thierry cost
à côté de moi à qui il avait fait la
bise en arrivant bonjour Nicolas bonjour
Thierry et la ligne en a marre il y en a
marre des lobbies il a acheté ses
feuilles en l'air et de toute façon je
démissionnerai demain alors personne
c'est trop inquiété parce qu'il a donc
comme il annonçait quatre fois par jour
c'était pas trop grave bon il s'est
avéré que cette fois là c'était la bonne
donc j'ai eu la démission de Nicolas
Hulot en direct lors de cette
avant-première effectivement le
lendemain matin sur France Inter il
annonçait sa démission tout à fait alors
on poursuit cette émission puisque on en
parlait tout à l'heure les sangliers qui
prolifèrent au grand dames des
agriculteurs et qui et bien soupçonne
les chasseurs de les nourrir en douce
c'est le dessous des plats
dites-moi si je me trompe ou il sera il
y aurait plus de 2 millions de sangliers
en France et bien vrai on peut passer on
peut pas parler de ce chiffre je pense
qu'on peut parler de ce chiffre
puisqu'on en tu pratiquement un million
tout au moins entre 1 million 5 et 2
millions on doit pas être loin de
millions donc une prolifération qui
cause des troubles dans les campagnes
avec des centaines d'hectares de culture
dévastée des gars la charge des
chasseurs chargé de les tuer pour
réguler leur nombre alors pour limiter
les dégâts les chasseurs pratiquent
aussi la grenade il verse en forêt du
maïs pour éloigner les sangliers des
champs une pratique légale très
réglementée qui divise au sein même des
chasseurs et des agriculteurs les
explications de Marion Becker
vous a grinez souvent tous les jours
à place disperser du maïs pour maintenir
les sangliers dans la forêt et éviter
qu'ils ne se dirige vers les champs
c'est ce qu'on appelle la grenade comme
sur ses vidéos amateurs pour qu'un
animal reste sur un secteur il faut
qu'il se nourrisse donc nous on est là
pour comprendre ce qui se passe dans la
nature et compenser les aléas
climatiques et les faits que à un moment
donné les animaux n'ont pas à manger en
forêt donc il faut faire cet agréable de
dissuasion sans ça je vous répète ils
sortent en pleine pour Guy Harley de
fauve c'est l'un des moyens de maîtriser
les dégâts sur les cultures nombreux ici
dans l'Oise la pratique est très
encadrée par les préfectures et les
fédérations de chasse ici ce chasseur de
laine a même une machine qui agraine à
sa place moi je le programme une fois
tous les jours à 6h du matin
voilà ça compte pendant à peu près 10
secondes et vous avez trois cinq kilos
de maïs qui tombent dans l'Oise ces
agrès noirs automatiques sont interdits
et pour agréer il faut y être autorisé
et avoir signé une charte quand vous
avez des chasseurs sur votre territoire
qui utilise des agrès noirs automatiques
et ils sont très malins parce que nous
avons un contrôle qui est très sévère et
si c'était le cas nous les sanctionnons
lourdement par des amendes et surtout
nous partons partie civils en les
mettant responsabilité pour les dégâts
qu'ils ont causé du fait de leur
de des attraits qu'ils ont fait pour une
population en surnom qui ont
automatiquement créé des dégâts aux
alentours donc ils ont la double panne
vous avez employé chasseur c'est pour
moi c'est pas des chasseurs
donc
la télé comme vous voulez pour moi je me
sens pas du tout solidaire avec ce type
de pratique on enclos on nourrit les pas
l'enjeu c'est la prolifération des
sangliers car les écologistes et
certains agriculteurs estiment quand les
nourrissant elle les chasseurs
favorisent leur multiplication qui eux
estiment au contraire que la grainage
leur permet d'atteindre leur plan de
chasse c'est-à-dire le nombre d'animaux
à abattre pour réguler l'espèce
alors même si on n'est pas chasseur on
comprend bien que ça divise parce que
moi je n'arrive pas bien comprendre la
logique de la grenade mais vous allez
nous expliquer mais alors est-ce que
vous êtes d'abord
allez on nourrit les cochons comme ça
les sangliers il y en a de plus en plus
oui bien sûr
de l'élevage de sangliers je vais vous
expliquer le contexte mondial de cette
espèce mondiale même c'est important
parce qu'on pourrait dire que les
chasseurs français si les chasseurs
français là le sanglier explose sur tous
les continents le bon exemple j'aime
bien prendre et qui est facile pour moi
mais voilà c'est comme ça c'est les
États-Unis aucune culture de chasse de
l'espèce on fait pas de battu une chasse
à la proche et c'est vraiment un animal
qu'on regarde même pas l'année passée
aux États-Unis les dégâts sur les sur
les cultures 1,5 milliards de dollars
fait des sangliers milliards de dollars
donc qu'est-ce qu'ils font eux ils
mettent des gens avec des mitraillettes
dans des hélicoptères vous y retrouverez
ces séquences qu'on voit beaucoup sur
Youtube ils abattent les animaux avec
des armes à répétitions voilà c'est
quasiment bien dehors de sangliers
voilà donc 1,5 milliards de dollars
certes les États-Unis c'est plus grand
que la France il y a aucune volonté
siégétique vis-à-vis de l'espèce nous
tout compte fait même si c'est important
en dégâts on contient quand même cette
espèce malgré tout voilà et des années
et le bon exemple de la ganache c'est
cette année
courage pas justement la prolifération
mais aussi nous sommes chasseurs et on
la chasse on a du plaisir
ça veut dire que en fait vous devez sur
le territoire
de biodiversité donc on la préserve
comme les autres espèces oui donc vous
leur donnez à manger aussi alors
pourquoi ça c'est un peu déréglé
d'ailleurs pourquoi ça c'est un petit
peu déréglé je pense que c'est pas du
tout le fait des par contre c'est le
fait d'un autre problème qu'on a de plus
en plus aujourd'hui c'est les zones
nonchables en France sachez qu'il y a
quand même quasiment un entre le car et
le tiers du territoire national où on ne
peut plus chasser et donc là que
prolifère les sangliers principalement
parce qu'ils sont complètement de plus
en plus de code nous a quasiment été
retirés vous le savez voilà tout ce qui
est sur l'estran et les marées arrière
les taureaux il y a plus de chasse c'est
pas pourchasser plus c'est parce qu'on
demande on est bien assez sur le
territoire qui reste on a beaucoup
beaucoup de villages aujourd'hui ou de
petites villes qui mettent des zones en
disant on veut un partage de la nature
il y a le marais du village ou bien le
bois du village qui n'est pas chasse à
ce qui nous gêne pas non plus ce qui ne
va pas c'est que quand on met tout ça
bout à bout on se rend compte qu'on a un
problème où on n'arrive pas à équilibrer
les prélèvements sur ces animaux il
faudrait pas mieux réguler quand même
cette pratique de l'agrenage parce que
on voit bien ça crée beaucoup de dégâts
d'ailleurs vous payez pour ces dégâts
des agriculteurs c'est paradoxal
finalement des non c'est pas paradoxal
vous allez comprendre pour nous le
problème c'est quoi c'est le sanglier ou
c'est le dégât c'est le dégât c'est le
dégât donc à partir de là à partir du
moment où on paye comment se fait-il
qu'on n'a pas l'autorisation de gérer le
problème comme on le souhaite puisque
c'est nous qui payons la facture cette
année enfin l'hiver dernier il n'y a pas
eu une un seul free forestier en France
dans les forêts il y a pas un gland il y
a pas une fin il n'y a strictement rien
ça veut dire que ce soit des sangliers
que ce soit des chevreuils que ce soit
des cervidés n'importe quel animal ne
peut pas se nourrir cette année dans les
forêts françaises il est quoi qu'il
arrive obligé de sortir
il n'y a rien rien à manger donc si on
doit sortir donc il va dans les cette
année on a vraiment le cas de figure où
c'est à mon avis scandaleux qu'on
interdise la grainage dans beaucoup de
départements il y a très peu d'endroits
où on peut le faire c'est pas du tout la
majorité réglementation c'est une erreur
fondamentale puisque cette année on est
en train de faire exploser les dégâts
dans les cultures agricoles avec pas
pour forcément beaucoup d'animaux une
compagnie de 10 sangliers est capable de
ravager pendant des mois des dizaines on
voit même des sangliers dans les villes
est-ce qu'il y a besoin de sangliers
est-ce qu'il faudrait éteindre l'espèce
ou pas éradiquer vous imaginez nous on
devrait éradiquer une espèce d'abord on
n'arrête pas de se battre contre les
sangliers et il prolifèrent donc c'est
que il y a un truc qui fonctionne pas on
est bien d'accord je vous le dis ces
zones nonchables sont déjà un des plus
gros problème puisque 80% des dégâts de
sangliers se concentrent sur 10% du
territoire c'est tout c'est aussi simple
que ça et regardez le trait de côte
regardez effectivement les zones en
chassables regardons prenons le temps de
regarder la carte qu'il faudrait élargir
les zones de chasse pour vous pour
pouvoir mieux réguler
de plus les chasseurs ont suffisamment
d'espace par contre ce que je ne veux
pas non plus c'est qu'on paye pour des
territoires où on peut pas aller à la
chasse mais on doit payer l'entièreté
des dégâts sur les cultures agricoles et
là je voudrais que celui qui dit moi je
suis objecteur de conscience inegétique
je suis propriétaire de ma forêt je veux
pas de chasseur c'est son droit et c'est
normal sauf qu'on paye les dégâts c'est
lui qui les paye est-ce que vous êtes
mesuré l'impact de la grenade est-ce que
dans certaines régions dans certains
coins vous êtes dit quand on les quand
on n'agrène pas il y a tant de culture
détruite quand on agraine au contraire
ça les fixe et il y a moins de culture
et c'est vraiment très probant c'est
même comptable est-ce que vous l'avez
fait cette démonstration on le fait
partout on peut le faire et ça une
particularité surtout sans bande de
chasser c'est là c'est très important
parce qu'un sanglier qui se nourrit
ensuite se repose il peut aussi faire
des dizaines de kilomètres dans la nuit
donc quand vous avez des gens qui
agrènent le monsieur le dit très bien
bon il fixe l'animal il mange il dorme
il se bougent et ils dorment il le fait
vers 5-6 heures du matin donc quand vous
voulez chasser quand vous voulez
concentrer un peu ces animaux pour être
sûr de les trouver c'est grand l'espace
forestier en France et ben vous fait
vous agrainez et vous avez beaucoup plus
de réussite et là on peut bien contenir
la population on peut en laisser pour
qu'il y en ait toujours parce que
sanglier à sa place aussi comme
n'importe quel animal mais évitez qu'on
ait une explosion donc c'est à la fois
un outil pour la chasse c'est aussi un
outil pour diminuer l'impact sur les
cultures agricoles en périphérie des
forêts françaises c'est un excellent
outil ce qu'on doit pas faire c'est
ouvrir une porcherie à ciel ouvert en
mettant des des bennes entières de maïs
sur des monts d’état et ça il en est pas
question on n'a jamais demandé ça
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui on discute de
quoi au niveau agréable on parle nous on
demande des quantités qui sont l'ordre
de quelques kilos sans hectares voir au
jour à la semaine ou au mois donc on est
vraiment dans quelque chose de dissuasif
on n'est pas dans du nourrissage les
agriculteurs vous défendent
ils peuvent être partagés ou pas moi
j'ai pas de problème particulièrement
que le monde agricole eux ce qu'ils
veulent c'est pas de dégâts si demain on
peut correctement expérimenter cet
agréable sur l'ensemble du territoire
national éprouver que quand on fait
quelque chose de dissuasif ils ont au
moins de problèmes et moins de dégâts je
peux vous assurer que mon agricole ça
tout de suite d'accord une question sur
l'élevage des faisans pour la chasse
c'est autre chose là on n'est pas dans
la régulation de l'espèce est-ce que ça
vous choque
non donc on élève des animaux pour les
tuer on est vraiment dans l'esprit de la
chasse mais pas dans la régulation de
l'espèce tous les animaux alors quoi
qu'on a une différence pour nous mais je
vous l'expliquer qu'est-ce qu'on fait
tous les animaux qu'on mange
probablement que ça dorade et d'élevages
je le crains je le crains
malheureusement mais c'est probablement
une dorade de l'élevage bon il y a donc
on élève l'état d'animaux nous on élève
des animaux effectivement pour la chasse
d'abord pour les réimplanter dans la
nature où ils ont pour beaucoup disparu
voilà on a souvent des animaux
aujourd'hui particulièrement les la
population de petits gibiers sédentaires
toutes les toutes les oiseaux qui vivent
qui veut au niveau de nos territoires on
a une chute de biodiversité très
importante parce qu'on a une
incompatibilité avec une agriculture
dite moderne la taille des champs le
partenaire l'emblablement le machinisme
agricole beaucoup de choses sont
difficiles aujourd'hui on a
effectivement des élevages d'oiseaux qui
ont réintroduit pour une écrasante
majorité en période estivale pour
repeupler ses territoires c'est vrai
après qu'on en chasse je suis d'accord
avec vous et puis on a cette partie où
on appelle ça gibier de tir mais il faut
tout se dire c'est-à-dire vous lâchez
des oiseaux aller dans un champ de
betterave quelques heures avant la
chasse vous y allez vous tirez dessus
ces oiseaux ils ont quoi
ils sont magnifiques en plus et ils
savent parfaitement volés ça veut dire
que c'est le l'élevage le plus propre
qui existe et le mieux traitant pour
l'animal c'est pas un poulet de batterie
où ils sont à 4 dans une case dans une
case dans une caisse à lapin c'est pas
ça c'est des oiseaux qui doivent être
bons plumage et qui doivent
effectivement bien voler donc ils
doivent être en pleine forme donc il y
en a qui ont été élevés dans des
conditions irréprochables on élèverait
tous les animaux de consommation comme
on élève le JB pour la chasse bien on
aurait même nos opposants les gens qui
n'aiment pas ça n'auraient plus rien à
dire voilà et qu'on [__] en tant
quelques-uns et qu'on le mange et que
d'autres resteront sur le territoire et
qui serait implanteront et qui se
reproduiront où est le problème où est
le problème alors on va continuer avec
vous à parler de la chasse ou les
channes puisque le week-end bah les
Français aiment bien aussi aller se
balader en forêt seulement les
promenades sont souvent perturbées par
la chasse voire pire alors on en parle
et on met les pieds dans le plat
les forêts sont en partie des domaines
privés ou les propriétaires pratiquent
la chasse le week-end ils sont bordés de
chemin communaux où les promeneurs
aiment se balader en toute tranquillité
mais les coups de feu et les accidents
mortels compliquent la cohabitation
entre promeneurs et chasseurs notre
reporter Clément Perrault la constaté en
Sologne regardez
voici l'une des terres de chasse les
plus prestigieuses de France la Sologne
ces forêts ou le gibier est abondant
sont en grande majorité des domaines
privés les propriétaires yorganisent de
grandes parties de chasse à l'abri des
regards et dans des conditions
contestées
Raymond Louis est le président de
l'association des Amis des chemins de
Sologne il dénonce depuis des années
l'installation de clôture tout au long
de ses propriétés il me présentent un
cas particulièrement éloquent
ça c'est un grillage qui est enfoui
d'environ 40 cm dans le sol puis c'est
un grillage qui était solide déjà et ils
ont ils ont en surplus de ça hormis un
petit grillage comme un grillage à poule
voilà toute la petite faune peut plus
passer
en haut on peut s'imaginer que c'est
empêcher les cervidés de sortir de
l'enclos
le gibier se retrouve donc enfermé la
garantie pour les chasseurs de faire
carton plein ce qui se pratique là
dedans c'est plus de la chasse moi
j'appelle ça du ball-trap sur cible
vivante là-dedans alors là vous voyez
c'est une photo de chasse qui a été pris
par un de nos amis qui était invités à
cette chasse là et là ce que l'on voit
c'est du sans que l'on voit devant les
animaux là et il y en a combien là 110
115 jours là
je vois votre veste vous êtes vous-même
chasseur je suis chasseur je suis
chasseur depuis mon tout jeune âge j'ai
70 ans et vous voyez qu'il y a quelques
années de permis j'ai commencé à l'âge
de 16 ans nous quand on part à la chasse
on fait attention à l'éthique de la
chasse on respecte tout tout
les parties de chasse dans ces domaines
sont intensives
pour éviter de passer à proximité et se
promener en sécurité les randonneurs de
Sologne ont appris à s'organiser
la randonnée montrez-nous un peu s'il
vous plaît l'itinéraire une petite
boucle on va juste passer la sur le
mélange je vois madame vous avez un
gilet est-ce que c'est par rapport à la
chasse il faut que tout le monde soit
visible aussi bien les marcheurs que les
chasseurs est-ce qu'on peut pas
considérer étonnant de devoir finalement
s’équiper pour ne pas se faire tirer
dessus je pense que c'est du bon sens
c'est normal c'est beaucoup plus simple
quand on est en groupe avec un minimum
d'organisations de connaître les
propriétaires et de pouvoir savoir quel
chasse a lieu à tel jour plutôt que de
marcher en particulier et on va se
retrouver au milieu d'une chasse et on
sait pas
sauf qu'avoir les informations sur ces
chasses n'a rien d'évident
si la plupart de ces forêts sont privés
comment vous pouvez savoir si des chats
sont prévus c'est très difficile ma plus
grosse difficulté c'est ça c'est de
savoir quand il y a des chasses
très fermé on a l'impression si vous
voulez que que tout le appartient y
compris les chemins de commune les
randonneurs dénoncent donc un manque
d'information ces chasses privées à
l'heure actuelle ne font pas l'objet de
déclaration préalable
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez répondre à ces
promeneurs qui ont juste envie d'aller
se balader en toute tranquillité le
week-end dans les bois de le faire chez
eux qu'ils ont aucun problème
c'est-à-dire que 80% du territoire
national est privé en France la nature
n'est pas à tout le monde et les gens
qui racontent ça des mecs comme Jadot
des mecs comme Mélenchon tout est Open
allez-y promenez-vous la nature à tout
le monde c'est pas vrai c'est pas ça la
vraie vie parce qu'on a vu il y a des
passages communaux
au milieu de propriété privée et là il y
a des chemins effectivement ils sont
respectés parce qu'on peut se prendre
une balle perdue on peut toujours se
prendre une balle perdue mais le
rassurez-vous vous avez beaucoup plus de
chance d'être tués par un assassin en
France que d'être tué par un seul soeur
puisqu'il y a moins d'une personne par
an malheureusement d'ailleurs et c'est
toujours un drame qui décède à la chasse
vous voyez quand même dans la psychose
dans laquelle on est aujourd'hui au
niveau de la
CGTS de champagne
perdre la vie à la chasse quand ils sont
non chasseurs en 30 ans le nombre de
coups de carabine a été multiplié par 10
en France le nombre d'accidents tout
confondu divisé par 4 on fait plus qu'un
effort
alors pourquoi on commence pas par Eddy
éradiquer les frelons asiatiques il y a
eu plus de 20 personnes qui sont mortes
l'année dernière en ce moment en forêt
tué par des piqûres de frelon asiatique
il y a en moyenne 3 5 crimes par jour en
France ou agression violente on en parle
les frelons alors qu'on peut être dans
la chasse sur tout le territoire comme
certains le prône qui ont pris ça un
petit peu comme une arme politique en
essayant de faire une campagne
sur un passage communal
attention à la nature du chemin beaucoup
chemin en France sont privés sont des
chemins privés des forestiers et des
chemins privés des agriculteurs donc
faut jamais oublier ça peu de chemin
sont publics il y en a mais pas tous ils
sont balisés dans ce cas là ce que j'ai
vu là c'est pas balisé donc ça veut dire
que sont des soins des chemins d'accès
de débardage
de la chasse doit signaler chasse en
cours
Brigitte que cette histoire de le
partage de la nature vous rendez compte
combien c'est récent on a tous connu la
campagne enfin des gens comme moi on
s'est promené partout il y a des gens
qui se promenaient partout il y a des
gens qui chassent les gens qui se
promenaient qui ramassent les
champignons qu'elle a la pêche qui
viennent du cheval on n'a jamais senti
la moindre haine entre ces personnes il
y avait une propriété privée ça se
respectait quand le propriétaire est à
la chasse bah oui foutait la paix ou
quand il est à la pêche on lui foutait
la paix ou quand il se promenait que son
cheval on lui foutait la paix ou quand
il faisait du vélo on lui foutait la
paix et tout allait bien maintenant vous
avez des gens qui disent tout ça c'est à
moi je fais ce que je veux moi je ne
vais pas le samedi ou le dimanche
déjeuner chez quelqu'un au hasard parce
que ça me fait plaisir c'est une
propriété privée il y a pas de problème
de sécurité aujourd'hui ou il faut
trouver quand même des solutions pour
améliorer cette les chiffres on a fait
un effort sur la sécurité que personne
ne fait mieux que la voiture on rajoute
en plus maintenant des formations
décennales tout au long de la vie d'un
chasseur plus ça quand je serai
président tous les 10 ans vous devez
effectivement accepter de faire une
formation si vous la refusez vous ne
chassez plus On vous retire votre permis
pour la sécurité pour la sécurité il y a
des commissions maintenant qui statues
dans toutes les fédérations la moindre
personne sans qu'au provoquer un
accident mais par une attitude
répétitive qui peut amener effectivement
un danger pour lui un homme ou lui-même
pour autrui on lui retire le permis je
veux dire on a fait des choses en
matière de sécurité les chiffres
attestent cette bête vous cohabitez pas
très bien ça veut dire qu'il y a quoi un
problème de communication entre vous
parce que les médias vendent ça écoutez
on a eu
mais oui comment ça se fait que des
chaînes d'information ont pu faire
pendant une semaine quand il y a eu un
mort vous l'avez vu il y a quelques
semaines pendant une semaine Aurillac tu
te fais le 13h et le 20h en ouverture il
faut une guerre en Ukraine pour calmer
tout ça celui qui connaît pas il regarde
sa limite il y a 50000 personnes qui me
relâchent tous les jours
accident ça veut encore dire quelque
chose dans ce pays vous croyez que cette
gamine elle a voulu tuer l'autre un
accidents une gamine de 17 ans qui tue
une autre elle aurait pu presque le même
âge il y a 40 ans il y a 40 ans il y a
40 enfants qui sont écrasés sur les
passages piétons tous les ans on en
parle pas faire une commande
je pense qu'il faut juste se calmer nous
on a fait beaucoup d'efforts et
peut-être comme disait cette dame elle a
sûrement raison il y a peut-être un peu
de bon sens vous savez que vous vous
promener en dehors de votre périmètre
privé de votre maison de votre jardin et
ben si tout le monde m'était agit les
plus haut ça irait beaucoup mieux nous
on le fait et pourquoi les autres ne le
font pas on met des panneaux pour se
promener là
un chasseur sa chasse 15 jours par an en
moyenne avec quand même pas me dire une
année c'est 365 jours chasse pas le bras
l'été un des deux jours du week-end
allez peut-être la vie non
les week-ends
c'est même mieux que ça les premiers
animaux que j'ai tué je les ai tué dans
un parc grand gibier parce que je suis
je suis né à la campagne on faisait que
le petit B moi j'assume parfaitement
voilà j'ai fait ça dans le département
de la Marne j'ai des animaux qui peuvent
même qui ont des enclos qui ne peuvent
pas courir de l'enclos mais quand même
il y a un moment vous avez une double
barrière les animaux une double histoire
qui sont contre la barrière il suffit de
les enclos qui font aller entre 600 et
2000 hectares d'éthique ça vous c'est
pas un problème d'éthique pour vous
c'est chasse aucun problème avec ça à
partir du moment aucun problème avec
rien mais non parce que je pense que
tout ce qu'on fait me paraît tout à fait
comment
s'échapper pourquoi on mettrait une
éthique pendant la chasse et qu'on
mettrait pas une éthique pour les autres
cages d'autres animaux ce sont des
propriétés privées est-ce que les
animaux sauvages appartiennent à ses
propriétés privées une fois que c'est
clos c'est reste nulus effectivement il
aura parfait pour grillager toutes les
propriétés il y a un moment je comprends
ces gens quand vous êtes à la chasse
chez vous vous êtes là ça m'arrive plein
de fois et que le mec qui passe à côté
de vous avez mis un panneau chasse en
cours qui s'en fout qui donne un coup de
pied dedans qui traite encore de gros
cons et qui traverse ta propriété tout
en t'insultant et en défiant et en
prenant un risque moi si le mec il veut
mourir d'une balle qui se la tire
lui-même moi j'ai pas envie de tuer
quelqu'un pour le promeneur mais pour la
sauce
pour terminer quand même là-dessus la
dérive qui se fait aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il y a des gens qui disent mais on en
a marre on est chez nous on peut même
pas la chasse et de finir de bien sûr on
est chez nous et on finit par oui slogan
mais et les mecs finissent par mettre un
grillage ce que je ne partage pas
alors le grillage c'est d'abord et avant
tout pour se protéger des gens
effectivement et des intrusions sur des
propriétés
de sangliers en France vous aurez
vraiment qu'on a besoin de remettre dans
les enclos c'est pas un problème en
Sologne il y a plein de sangliers
une fois que vous avez tout tué sur
votre propriété
alors les animaux d'une espèce alors
possible donc il y en aura toujours dans
ces enclos se reproduisent parce que une
fois qu'on a tué tout le monde comment
on fait on va chercher des espèces et on
les réintroduit comme dans un safari
comme dans du tout gère parfaitement ce
qu'il y a à l'intérieur ils sont obligés
on n'a pas le droit de réintroduire
c'est interdit donc c'est des gens qui
ont qui régulent leur population de de
chevreuil venons-en au tableau voilà mec
il a mis 150 €, 530 pièces 115 bon ça
vous choque pas
qu'est-ce qui est mieux secouer le
territoire on va dire les chasser trois
fois la semaine et tu à chaque fois un
sanglier et faire 130 jours de chasse
par an ou une fois chasser son
territoire et tuer son 30 animaux et
leur [__] la paix le reste du temps ça
se discute ça se discute on est pas dans
la chasse intensive là quand même
justement au contraire on est dans la
dans le repos de la nature moi je
préfère des gens qui ont un territoire
qui le chasse peu mais quand il chasse
moi je lui dis toujours de le faire
comme ça quand on chasse il faut chasser
on est là pour chasser on chasse je
préfère un territoire qui repose où il y
a moins de chasse mais quand on fait une
chasse on fait une belle chasse et s'il
y a 50 ans 50 ici on a 100 y en a 100
allez entendu alors juste une petite
question deux chasseurs dit dans le
reportage parfois on entend des tirs
d'armes automatiques est-ce que il a
fabulé ou est-ce que c'est ça peut être
vraiment qu'on tire des bêtes et du
gibier à l'arme automatique mais ça on
n'a pas le droit donc si quelqu'un le
fait c'est pas le droit de donc
je peux toujours le faire bon alors non
franchement non je pense pas donc ce
chasseur a affablé le fusil ou quand
c'est le gros gibier à balle prévenir
davantage au moins prévenir la
municipalité faudrait pas que ce soit
bah quand on chasse sur son territoire à
Bâle est-ce qu'il faudrait pas
automatiquement prévenir la municipalité
dites-vous bien Brigitte que dès qu'on
chasse un territoire public c'est le cas
vous prenez l'Office national des forêts
les forêts ce qu'on appelle domaniales
les forêts publics vous avez sur
Internet les jours de chasse
portion de forêt par portion de forêt
que tout le monde peut consulter et à
l'entrée de la forêt le panneau qui
donne le calendrier rappelé à chaque
entrée de forêt des jours de chasse je
veux dire à partir de là on sait où sont
les chasseurs ce qu'ils font d'ailleurs
c'est les seuls qui payent pour aller
dans la forêt tous les autres
propriétaires privés le fassent si c'est
bordé de chemin communaux
vous êtes chez vous vous êtes chez vous
voilà les gens qui s'instirent pas à
travers les chemins communaux même qui
traversent
pour les quelques jours de chasse qu'on
pratique tous sur nos territoires que ce
jour-là ma légende simplement ils
aillent dans un autre coin de la commune
et ça irait très bien juste un peu de
respect un peu de partage d'intelligence
quoi juste dire allez ah oui bah on
connaît bien il chasse une dizaine de
dimanche par an bah on fout la paix ces
10 dimanches là mais c'est pas grave on
aura les 42 qui restent pour nous et ce
serait pas beaucoup plus simple
entendu allez on avance et on va passer
au dessert c'est le péché mignon
alors wishra depuis que je sais que vous
observez un régime j'ai rangé mes
blagues de potage plus vraiment
du sucré mais là j'imagine que bah vous
avez plus le droit de sucré si vous avez
pris du fromage non là par contre je
l'ai pris parce que j'ai une passion
immodéré
mais je peux manger tout c'est pour ça
j'ai mis un anneau oui
là on est dans mon plaisir
noix par contre quel scandale de l'eau
même pas un bon verre de vin pour manger
fromage vous êtes pas très sucré
j'aurais si j'aime tout tu défends
corporelle qui la teste il y a pas grand
chose qui me déplaît à table voilà vous
votez Roussel vous non communiste parce
que du fromage du bon vin vous êtes dans
les j'aurais pu le faire s'il était pas
copain avec Mélenchon qui veut arrêter
la chasse ah ça y est on a compris
si vous aviez un dessert parce que c'est
normalement c'est le temps du dessert ça
devient un dessert que vous aimez et que
de temps en temps vous faites une petite
entorse ah mais j'ai je fais des
entorses je le redis c'est quoi votre
dessert préféré j'ai un dessert préféré
que tout le monde sait dans ma famille
qui me passionne c'est le baba au rhum
ah voilà
le baba au rhum c'est vraiment pour moi
alors
ce gâteau je vous dirais quel est le
meilleur baba au rhum de Paris
vous me le direz alors je vais goûter
avec plaisir qu'on finit toujours cette
émission en musique on vous a demandé de
choisir une musique on va l'écouter
ensemble et vous nous dites pourquoi
après
ce matin un lapin a tué un chasseur
alors c'est la guerre des étoiles salut
vous surprendre ça un petit peu
possible un peu intello classique tout
ça moi vous me connaissez j'ai des
fautes dire toujours ce que je pense et
comment demander une musique je me suis
dit qu'est-ce qui m'a vraiment marqué
comme musique et quand vous avez 10 ans
et que vous allez peut-être pour une des
premières fois de votre vie au cinéma
et que vous êtes gamin et que vous ayez
le film commence et c'est marqué en
grand sur l'écran la guerre des étoiles
et vous avez cette musique qui commence
alors ça m'a profondément marqué c'est
c'est vraiment des films que je regarde
tout le temps ce qui est une musique qui
me donne une émotion ça a été vous êtes
gamin aujourd'hui les gamins ils ont
tous téléphone la guerre des étoiles
avec des bestioles avec des poils des
ailes des Jedi des sables lasers c'était
une révolution Lucas qui nous a amené ça
et cette musique et se défiler de des
phrases qu'on voyait tout doucement sur
le générique d'ouverture voilà cette
musique m'a vraiment fait quelque chose
et je regarde trois quatre fois par an
d'ailleurs tous les épisodes de La Garde
et toi
en musique grâce à vous merci Ethan de
nous avoir accompagné pendant ce
déjeuner merci à chez Françoise qui a
cuisiné c'est mon petit plats comme
d'habitude merci Jean-Pierre merci à
vous tous de nous avoir suivis on je
trouve bien sur la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau numéro de politique à
table sur LCP
[Musique]